[Music]
all right did you see a quick setup here
Rogan's had it with Bert Kreischer now I
didn't know this and too lazy to try
about to explain it for us but
did you know Bert Kreischer has some
sort of beef with Garth Brooks have you
heard about this day about this have you
here
I haven't heard about this okay in this
video we have Joe Rogan getting annoyed
with bird Chrysler once again and he
gives him the Brian Cowan treatment and
tells him to shut the f up in the top
three comments on this clip are talking
about how they appreciate Joe for doing
this this person said Joe stopping Bert
from derailing this whole entire clip
was the key moment we need more people
who would tell Bert to shut the f up
like Joe did honestly all right so let's
get into the clip here first I'll just
give some content I'm sorry too lazy to
try but I believe you meant to say let's
get after it yeah let's get after it too
lazy come on bro
they're talking about Garth Brooks and
if you're familiar with Tom segura's
podcast they talk I am not I am a lot
and they troll him and their fans troll
him like
why are they trolling Garth Brooks
what was the other character he had he
remember Garth Brooks Gaines Chris
Gaines yeah I'm more of a Chris Gaines
man myself all of Garth Brooks social
media accounts are just Tom Segura fans
messing with him in the comments so Joe
asked Tom if Garth agreed to do Tom's
podcast would he stop messing with him
and Tom's like yeah I'd love to have him
on and he says he thinks his fans would
even stop messing with him but then
Bird's like oh it doesn't even matter
because Garth would never do his podcast
yes he would if Joe Rogan called Garth
Brooks and said hey man I'll have you on
my show but can you also do bird or not
even that I'll have you on my show but
Bert kreisch is going to be here I think
it'll be fun he would come on he's Garth
Brooks why wouldn't he go on the biggest
podcast in the world and he keeps saying
there's no reason for it and Tom has
nothing to offer there'd be no point of
him going on there and he's getting like
really passionate about it and Joe and
Tom are trying to explain to him that
it's good for him to do because then the
fans had stopped trolling him and it'd
just be a good interview like he has
nothing to worry about because Tom and
Joe obviously want to see it happen it
seems like bird doesn't want him to go
on there for some reason you'd be
willing to drop this if Garth Brooks
would come on the podcast
for sure
why would that never happen Garth gosh
that should happen oh here it is a job
you're a genius yes Garth you should
make this happen and then for everybody
we love you where are the bodies
look how quickly they pulled that camera
away they didn't just switch cameras
they backed out of it yeah I don't get I
mean I don't watch Tom segura's podcast
because I like comedy but why
um I mean why do we make fun of half the
[ __ ] and become hyper focused no no I I
probably just had a running gag I'm not
making fun of him about it I'm honestly
just trying to understand I'm wondering
what I'm you know what I mean I'm
getting the impression it's just funny
it's the running gag on this show and he
probably was just [ __ ] on Garth
Brooks all the time is it goof fair
enough and then it just kind of
backfired in his fan it probably you
know it's like we've added Apple where
your show gets bigger than you expected
people start [ __ ] with people I mean
you have to go guys don't [ __ ] with it
just kinda
hope her Chrysler brings up the machine
again you know like that for me would be
a big deal
see how they backed out like wait what
is that oh [ __ ] but wait yeah there's no
bed under water there's no benefit for
Garth to go on the podcast
first of all they're very nice people
both Tom and Christina are very nice
this is so funny
shut the [ __ ] up for a second and they'd
be happy oh did you see finally thank
you oh watch Yo okay okay I'm gonna say
now thank you Joe thank you thank you
thank you the only reason other people
don't tell them to shut up is because
he's Joe's friend you still got it yeah
[ __ ] forever
yes
shut the [ __ ] up for a second the shut
the [ __ ] up heard around the world that
hurt him too look at his face I mean
here if you slow it down you can see the
exact moment Rogan broke his heart right
hold on right
yeah there right there we got it right
there
bro it's gonna have to send him my choo
choo Choose You card later
and they'd be happy I love it let's be
friends let's be friends you're right
it's got a picture of a bee on it
s face after that it's like he didn't
even know what just happened and you
could tell Joe's just getting annoyed
because Burr keeps talking over him but
also Joe obviously wants to see Garth on
Tom's podcast so he wants to make it
sound like it'd be something beneficial
you stop sandbagging us that's the other
thing it's like yeah can you stop
torpedo I'm trying to hook my body up
with a cool [ __ ] show but that's the
other thing it's like it's also [ __ ]
dumb because like
what what would why would it be a
problem like I don't understand what
Chrysler's issue is here if if Garth
Brooks goes on right
it would be like probably the biggest
podcast he's ever had like so I don't
understand like what's the issue here
you know
very nice people both Tom and Christina
are very nice
shut the [ __ ] up for a sec
big when you're really well I think
they're one of his important months when
okay that's pretty much more of an
audience
um I'm sure we can find out more about
the Garth Brooks things but I don't
really care that much my point is is
that good please I think Rogan has he
did it he did it to Brandon remember
Brennan said he apologized b b hey b
yeah he text me yo bro he text me well
they're cool you know they're cool now
right
even though Rogan's never apologized on
air and even even though all his friends
are hanging out uh Brandon normally said
these things he's not anymore why does
Brendan not get invited anymore